AUTHORITIES GOINTHROUGVIDEO,
S SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS
THE INDIVIDUALS
MUCH. AMERICANS. >>FLS
>>> NO UNE
MONT AND BLO RUSSI VERGE OE
EASTERN FI NDNIAN
RERAWINGAND IN
KYTO
RCENARY FIGHTERS WERPLANTING TH
, VICTAST FEW DAYSUSFORCES MADES
ENCILI BAKUT
AROUND CITY ENPRESSING INTM THE
EAWEO
E  GROUP.
EY HAVE BEEN LEADING THE W
AROUAK
PLANTEDIRTHRUOGNENDSETHEI
THE M T
ZELENSKYY'OFHTY NT DEFEND
THEI DEFEND THCITYD EINFORCING
IDEIS.
AVINT AREA
TH
E'S BEEN A LOT OF TIME
SUPPLUTBE
I LLOUT ISVE
G ATTACKEDRUSSIA.GI
BR
ANNOUNCED IF WERTO DES IN IT
WIWOULD
MAT WOULVEEN
OV THAT N'STINE IS
E TORADEFOUYFOR
A PLANNED COUNTEOFFENS
IT WOULD NOT B STRATEGIC CORAN
IN THIS FIT.Y  LOSRAINE.THEY ALM
THEYAVST PROFESSIONAL LEE RUSSIA
DEO MANYLLED HAV
CONVICTS IN MET THE
KN WOULD BE OR HOW STRATEGIC
IT WOULDONE LAST THINGI DID SPE
DO MONEYTHEY SAY THEY  WOULD GO,
SCARED, 'RED OUT
ON THAT ROAD A
H KWERT  TSAHE POINT AWAS AT
COMES ITY OF. THEREOF WHEN I
OYD AUSTN THE  T
SRY  SY ISN'ATC VALU
IT THE
SUVEOUT THAT GIVES YOU
AGAND ST  ITHROWING AINS IT
O TAHMUT BUTN SAYING THIVIORWHA
I WOULD NOT VIOTR STRAT
I E  SYMBOC  AND
ISS IN TO E ON A DLYASIS
POUR IED ANDOPANOOPS AER
THTY IELE, IT IMPORTANT DECISIO
DECIDE, WHERE UKRAINE THAT IS TN
RIGHT NOING THATFIGHT HEOF
STRATEGIC DESI.RAINE REALIZING D
WILL BE THE NIN
WHICH THEY FIGHT THEUS
AND  PHA ANOTHER REASON
AE N ST FIGHT FOR TY OF ONASBOY
FES SPRING,
AS WELL.
RAL, GOOD TO SEE Y.CLARK IS MILE
I'M GET YOUR FROSEING IN HIS
RETREATROT NOBETIAL
ATEGIC SET BACE  DAYE'RING UN
NG I
FOEM
E  PS POINT?
AW,U LOOK AMUOKS TO TEXT REALL.
PRESSURE IONE OF THEIC OERK PH
D THINITIAL IAN AST.WE DONEE
NESSRCE HEN RAING UP
SO TESHING.
SECRETAR
IT'SBLT GR
PSYCHOLOGICAW O
AND AT SOMSSIAN
E
THEY HAVE TO BE
THAT LINAS YIBLY C. U BROU THAT
NGVERYONE IS UAIS BECAUSE I'M
WONDET BENEFIT,ONTHS REALLY DID
BENEFIE TOE
LIATINGU
OP
AT
HA
T DOES TPON
IANSLSSIEI TUS RAT
AMMU YR TH
MA T
THEY'RE AN?THEIRD THEY DO SURREE
T
WEST.
THEAMON A BN THE  VEHOLD.THEY .
RAOT TO GET THEM MOR AY'
A HAE HOIN
THRE
THI AND IT'S THEIROUNTRY ANDHE
TO T  PT
ITION THATS REQUIRINAT
W ONTA
AT ALST BATTLEAT
T
RUSSIANSY AT HE WROTE.
ARING
ITWIRATEGIC PONFRASTRUURCCUPYIN
THCH IN THE CAPTURVOLUMES ABOUT
CASSIAN R.'RE ANRIN COMMANOSINGR
IF YOU'RE A RUSSIAN CODER ORP,SP
USE THEM UYOA
BREAKTHROUN T